JAMES CLEWETT: What we've done
is I've got a radiation source
which is emitting a constant
stream of electrons.
As neutrons are decaying into
protons, out pops an electron,
and I'm counting not how many
it's giving out, but how many
of them are going into
the Geiger counter.
That's a slightly different
number.
MALE SPEAKER: And what kind
of ballpark figures are we
talking here?
JAMES CLEWETT: Well--
MALE SPEAKER: You must know
because [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES CLEWETT: Yes.
So it's about 20 per second
going into the Geiger counter.
And then I'm feeding that into
this little box, which is just
turning that number
into a voltage.
So these two wires are
collecting that voltage, and
they're passing them into the
oscilloscope, where we can see
the pulses as they go by.
Each pulse represents
one electron.
And electrons are all the same,
so those pulses are all
the same height.
And so as those pulses flash
by, I'm counting them, the
computer is counting them.
So the wire comes out of the
oscilloscope, it goes through
this little breakout box and
into the back of the computer.
You can buy one of these
things for about 200
quid, by the way.
They're worth having.
Into the back of the computer,
and then I've written a little
computer program.
And all the computer program
does is sit there for 10
seconds and count pulses.
That's it.
It's really simple.
It's all graphs today.
Here's time along here, and the
stream of electrons looks
something like this as they're
coming out, and they're
randomly distributed, which my
stream of electrons absolutely
isn't there.
It's getting less random
by the second.
And all I'm doing
is I'm counting.
So I start with a value of 0,
and then I get to this time,
and I'm adding 1.
I get here, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, and so on.
And this is where the
probability bit comes in
because the chances are
that over 10 seconds--
remember this graph?
So the most likely number that
we're going to get here--
I measured this this morning--
is 216.
MALE SPEAKER: Over 10 seconds?
JAMES CLEWETT: Over
10 seconds.
And that's just an empirical
measurement.
So I'm taking the number that
I've counted up, and I'm going
to subtract off 216.
What we've just seen, and
whether the answer was 13,
then obviously either
I've come in here--
and I'm going to get
this right--
I've had 229, or it could
equally be that I've been here
and had 203.
Both of those are going to
give the answer of 13.
So the reason that's happened
is I wasn't interested in
showing you a negative
random number.
I wanted to show you an integer
value, a positive
integer value.
So I just wrote a piece
of software where
I squared it up.
I took the square root.
The square root's inevitably
positive, and so my software
is always going to give
a positive answer.
I cheated.
OK, I admit it.
But the answer is 13.
So you want some more
numbers, right?
OK, well I'll generate
a few more.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's do 10
and write them down
as they come out.
JAMES CLEWETT: All right.
Yeah, good idea.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, a big one.
Or is that big?
We don't know yet?
JAMES CLEWETT: We
don't know yet.
So should we start with the 0
and the 13, or do you want to
just start with the 13?
MALE SPEAKER: No, put them.
So we've got a 0, a 13.
JAMES CLEWETT: So we have
had 0, we've had 13.
Now, we have 27, 5.
MALE SPEAKER: They should do
the lottery like this.
JAMES CLEWETT: They really
should use radiation sources
for the lottery.
Nobody would be cheating,
for sure.
It doesn't quite have the
razzmatazz of the lottery.
44, last seen three
weeks ago today.
MALE SPEAKER: Hang
on a second.
This would be a bad way to do
the lottery because some
numbers here are more likely
than other ones.
JAMES CLEWETT: Right.
That's a really good point
that you've made.
There's some maths which I left
out of this video because
I thought it was going too
far, where you can turn a
Gaussian distribution into
a uniform distribution.
So you can take your Gaussian
distribution of random
numbers, and you can flip it
around and give them all a
uniform probability.
Now, I don't want to do the
maths for you because that
would be painful for everybody,
but it works.
And so you can, then, generate a
uniform probability sequence
of numbers.
MALE SPEAKER: But we
haven't done that.
JAMES CLEWETT: That's
absolutely
not what we've done.
What we've done is we've taken
a Gaussian distribution, and
so some numbers--
0, basically-- are going to be
more likely than others.
I'm really quite
enjoying this.
It's very satisfying.
3.
I'll run another one.
We'll count up.
So the computer, again, is
counting 200ish electrons, and
this is the deviation.
6 is the deviation
from the mean.
And because it's got a Gaussian
distribution, the
smaller numbers are
more probable.
So if we keep doing this, what
we're going to end up with is
very heavily weighted to
the small numbers.
It's actually quite surprising
to me that we haven't
seen 0 again yet.
I should say this morning--
9, excellent.
This morning before you arrived,
I ran thousands of
these just to check that it was
Gaussian, not that nature
was suddenly going to do
something different.
So the computer is counting the
number of electrons that
strontium's putting out, and in
this case, it's either put
out 20 more than the average
number of electrons, or it's
put out 20 less.
I can't tell because I've
hidden that in my code.
But it's 20 away from
the average.
So in the science of statistics,
this is--
10, excellent.
In the science of statistics--
sorry.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
all right.
Can you have George [INAUDIBLE]
something?
JAMES CLEWETT: On your
head be it, George.
Thank you.
19.
So that's 19 more or less
electrons than the average
value that the strontium's
putting out.
So in this case, it's been quite
an active 10 seconds for
the strontium.
OK, 13.
MALE SPEAKER: We've
got 13 again.
We haven't got a 0 again.
JAMES CLEWETT: No,
it's surprising.
Anyway, so this is
the proof of it.
It could well be that I got the
mean in the wrong place.
That would explain it.
And eventually, that
would show up.
So there's one last thing I'd
like to show you, and that is
essentially--
well, let me just show you, and
then I can talk about it.
I'm going to run the experiment
1,000 times over,
and let me make that
nice and big.
So each one of these pulses that
you can see appearing,
that's one number that
we've generated.
And as you can see, we're
generating more and more
numbers, and each time, I'm
adding 1 to this pulse.
And so the most likely number
at the moment is 20.
MALE SPEAKER: It's not 0.
What does this tell us?
JAMES CLEWETT: This tells us
that I got the mean wrong.
So if I had got the mean
right, then this
value would be 0.
What this means is that I got
the mean wrong probably
by 20, which is--
MALE SPEAKER: The
mean being what?
JAMES CLEWETT: What this means
is that I've got the mean
number of electrons that this
thing's giving out in 10
seconds, I got that completely
wrong, which is a bit
embarrassing.
But you can see now that
it's starting to take
this Gaussian form.
So it started off just as a
couple of pulses, and you'd
never have known that
there was a Gaussian
distribution to that.
But over time, it grows into
a really nice, bell-shaped
graph, and we can see that the
most likely number that we're
going to generate has moved
up a bit from 20
now, it's about 22.
MALE SPEAKER: That also means
when we ran the experiment
earlier, and we got 0 as our
first result, that was
actually quite an
unlikely result.
JAMES CLEWETT: Yeah,
absolutely.
So that would mean that
effectively, 0 was more like a
20 result, and all of the 20s
and 19s that we got and the 27
that we got before, these
were much more likely.
So it wasn't perfect, but it
was all right, I think.
And I think that we got a nice
random number from it, so I'm
pretty pleased.
MALE SPEAKER: So that
was still random.
This doesn't effect the
randomness of the numbers.
JAMES CLEWETT: No.
Again, this goes back to
the semantics of it.
It's random, yes, but it has
a particular probability
associated with choosing
that number.
So at the moment, the
probability of choosing
something less than about 8 is
0, and the probability of
choosing something more
than 38 is 0.
If we go for a very, very long
time, an infinitely long time,
then these numbers will become
nonzero, but they're going to
be very close to 0.
MALE SPEAKER: We've got a little
outlier there down near
40, don't we?
JAMES CLEWETT: It's quite
satisfying just watching this
graph draw itself over time.
The question is, how much
time do you have?